todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saint click la gravedad
según newton
porque una manzana cae del árbol hacia
el piso y porque la luna órbita
alrededor de la tierra en el siglo 17 el
matemático y físico isaac newton
resuelve estas dos preguntas con una
sola solución la gravitación
qué es la gravitación
en el universo todos los objetos que
tienen masa se atraen mutuamente por
ejemplo la luna atrae a la tierra y la
tierra atrae a la luna ahora imaginemos
un primer objeto y un segundo objeto ve
separados por una cierta distancia
a causa de la gravitación estos dos
objetos se atraen
de este modo y se acercará a b&b se
acercará
si fuera más masivo la atracción
gravitacional sería más fuerte
inversamente si afuera de menor masa la
fuerza de la gravedad sería más débil
esto es igualmente cierto para be
[Música]
a su vez si los dos objetos estuviesen
más alejados la atracción gravitacional
sería más débil y si estuviesen cerca la
atracción gravitacional sería más fuerte
así la fuerza de gravedad de un objeto
ejercida sobre otro desaparece cuando
los dos objetos están muy lejos
tomemos ahora el ejemplo de una manzana
la manzana posee una cierta masa y la
tierra también por lo tanto la manzana
atrae a la tierra e inversamente la
tierra atrae la manzana
por eso la manzana y la tierra se
acercarán la una a la otra hasta que la
manzana toque el piso
ahora imaginemos que lanzamos la manzana
en una dirección con una determinada
velocidad al igual que antes la manzana
será atraída por la tierra pero también
se moverá en la dirección en la que fue
lanzada según su velocidad
cuanto más rápido se lance la manzana
más lejos caerá si pudiéramos lanzar la
manzana con una velocidad
suficientemente alta observaríamos que
es la velocidad contrarrestaría la
atracción gravitacional y la manzana
nunca caería al suelo
esto es lo que ocurre con la luna y por
eso la luna orbita alrededor de la
tierra así como con la tierra que orbita
alrededor del sol
[Música]